بالعوده للواقع الان والحديث عن وصول
الحرب الاوكرانيه لنقطه فاصله فاي هجوم
اوكراني مضاد سيتطلب الان دبابات القتال
حديثه بريطانيا اعلنت ارسال تشالنجر اثنين
واشنطن تدرسه
ابرامز لكن تبقى لي قد الالمانيه الاكثر
افاده لكي لماذا
تستخدم المحرك التوربيني الغازي عيبه
استهلاكه الكبير للغاز والجيش الاوكراني
لا يمتلك الكثير من الشاحنات الوقود مثل
الجيش الامريكي اما لا يطارد فتعتمد على
محرك تربونيه يعمل
مقارنه مع تشالنجر البريطانيه تمتلك لندن
2007 دبابات سترسل لاوكانيا 14 بينما
تمتلك الدول الاوروبيه
وبالتالي دعم اكبر من ناحيه العدد
ليبارد اثنين اربعه هي الاقدم بين كل
النسخ التي لا تزال في الخدمه لكنها تظل
اكثر تطورا من الدبابات السوفياتيه
القديمه التي تستخدمها اوكرانيا مثل التي
72 والتي تعاني قصورا تحديدا من ناحيه
الذخيره الخاصه بها 125 ملمترا لم تعد
تنتج حاليا في اوروبا وهي ميزه اخرى
لانها دخيلتها من عيال 120 مليمترا يتم
انتاجه في اوروبا حاليا وليوفره مشاهدينا
هذه الميزه قد تتحول الى عيب بسبب مساله
الامداد طويل الاجل نعم اخيرا الدبابات لا
تستهلك بنفس الكميات مثل ذخيره المدفعيه
لكن الوتيره وتيره الحرب وامكانيه ان تكون
اطول
هل تتطلب من المانيا تسريع انتاجي ذخيره
الدبابات وامر تعاني منه برلين اصلا في ما
يخص المدفعيه وواحدا من اسباب الانتقادات
التي طالت وزيره الدفاع السابقه المستقيله